the women's heart alliance and women
heart launching a national campaign to
encourage women to get their hearts
checked as coven 19 increases the risk
of stress and heart disease well denise
valdez is here in studio to tell us more
about it in today's health watch
denise well heart disease is the number
one killer of women in this country but
over the past decade awareness of it has
really declined a lot of women simply
don't realize the threat or know the
signs and now with covid two groups
really want to raise awareness of just
how prevalent and severe heart disease
can really be
i will be right by you
the national campaign women can have it
all even heart disease from women's
heart alliance and women's heart sounds
the alarm for women to check their heart
health ceo selena gore is concerned
about the rising rates in young women
especially women of color first thing to
do is check your blood pressure you know
know what that is know what normal is
for you
that's really important so that when you
see variations you know that something's
not quite right with so many worried
about kobit were often overlooking the
bigger threat and killer of women the
campaign urges them to schedule their
screening so your doctor will study a
number of things how's your cholesterol
do you have a history of hypertension
diabetes other risk factors like smoking
and drinking and this is a biggie have
you had any symptoms because they may
look different for men than they do
women indigestion nausea
unexplained and extreme fatigue and
weakness these are
symptoms that we see more often in women
and it's really easy for us to dismiss
those symptoms because they are so
generalized
[Music]
unique symptoms like jaw pain and back
ache are also highlighted in the public
service announcement
some of the other risk factors if you
have let's say an autoimmune disease
like lupus or rheumatoid arthritis early
onset menopause or undergone cancer
treatment now keep in mind 12 times as
many women die of heart disease every
year than they do from breast cancer by
the way women's heart is the nation's
only patient-centered group and they're
dedicated specifically to serving women
living with or at risk for heart disease
they've got a lot of great resources
online